I am so paranoid about my mouth and what it smells like
what my breath is like from this really mean person
I had a really crappy partner that used to manipulate me in arguments by saying
my breath stink
so soon as I would bring up an argument
he would be like
oh god your breath kinda smells
can we talk about this later
and I'd be like
oh my god like immediately
oh my god but like
all the time and I went
it gave me such dental paranoia
I went to the dentist
I got all kinds of work done on my mouth
and I asked the dentist like
okay the I
I'm good right
like there should
I mean I got a deep deep
I've done everything to my mouth
and he would still be like
girl
can we talk your breath
I can't what did you eat
and I would just be so paranoid
and that just stuck with me
like looking back now
that's bullshit that
that was just his
he knew that was the quickest way to get me to shut up and that's what he used
but it did give me and
and keep this like
paranoia about my mouth and the smell that comes from it
so I love this toothbrush from the TikTok shop
it got all these different settings
I just used a cleaning setting
but it does have
even for sensitive okay
the head of the brush is so small you can only put a pea sized amount
which is the appropriate amount
it's also small so it really fits in your mouth really nice and easily
it's like super comfy
I just I'm not even trying to be stupid
but that this toothbrush makes me feel very confident about my breath
like I know it's getting all up in there
it's linked right here if you wanna get one cause I love this thing